y
[Música]
el break si es un hecho el acuerdo
comercial entre el reino unido y la
unión europea ya es ley después de su
aprobación ayer en sesión especial del
parlamento y el visto bueno de la reina
esta mañana así lo anunció el primer
ministro boris johnson al estampar su
firma hoy a medianoche hora de bruselas
el reino unido- deja formalmente la
unión europea tenemos reporte desde el
hombres
al otro lado del canal el alivio por
haber logrado un acuerdo que el hombre
exit caótico se combina con preocupación
por lo que viene desde este primero de
enero las relaciones de la unión europea
con el reino unido- será con un tercer
país el pacto que también aprobaron los
líderes europeos inspirada su
ratificación final en el parlamento
europeo a fines de febrero tenemos
reacciones también en desde berlín
la humanidad vive un año nuevo atípico
en medio de repunte de casos de kobe 19
y nuevas medidas de los gobiernos que
buscan frenar la expansión del virus a
la fecha se cuentan más de 82 millones
820 mil casos confirmados y la cifra de
muertos supera el millón 807 mil la
fecha se celebra en medio de drásticas
restricciones y américa latina no es la
excepción
bienvenidos a una nueva mañana de
información de américa latina y del
mundo aquí en france 24 mi nombre es
liliana valencia iniciamos en europa
porque a partir de la medianoche de hoy
el break si se convierte en una realidad
esto después de que el acuerdo comercial
presentado por los equipos negociadores
el pasado 24 de diciembre fuera aprobado
por el parlamento británico y firmado
por la reina isabel
el pacto ya es ley en dar a regir a
partir de mañana primero de enero
previamente la presidenta de la comisión
europea ursula von der leyen y el
presidente del consejo europeo charles
michel habían firmado los tres textos
que integran el acuerdo así dice un
nuevo capítulo de la relación británica
con el bloque tras medio siglo de
integración europea y cuatro años y
medio de difíciles negociaciones que
llevaron al divorcio el 31 de enero de
este año ampliamos esta información con
nuestra corresponsal en londres louis ha
pulido luisa cuéntenos qué va a cambiar
a partir de mañana primero de enero y
cómo empiezan entonces estos primeros
momentos del divorcio oficial entre leer
un yo de la unión europea
en 11 horas el reino unido y la unión
europea iniciarán una nueva relación se
espera que menos conflictiva cambiará
todo pero hay que ver en los primeros
días de este 2021 cómo se va dando esa
transición gran parte fundamental de la
negociación es un nuevo acuerdo
comercial que empezará a regir en las
primeras horas de 2021 no habrá tarifas
ni cuotas está valuado por más de 600
billones de libras esterlinas del primer
ministro boris johnson dice además que
el reino unido- recupera su
independencia en leyes en fronteras en
presupuesto y en política cambiará
además la manera como los británicos y
los europeos vienen a este país y como
los británicos pueden tomar vacaciones
en europa esta noche no se tiene
prevista una celebración grande para
conmemorar este motivo pero a las 11 de
la noche el icónico 'big ben' sonará
nuevamente 2 de 2010 y 2017 gastado en
reparaciones y lo volverá a hacer a las
12 de la noche para darle la bienvenida
el 21 luisa pero también a partir de la
medianoche de hoy los ciudadanos
británicos son considerados ciudadanos
de tercer país en la unión europea cómo
afectará esto la vida de quienes viven
en países del bloque
cada país europeo tendrá su propia regla
migratoria para los ciudadanos
británicos que residen especialmente en
europa en países del mediterráneo pero
también el reino unido- estrenará mañana
en 11 horas un nuevo sistema migratorio
para quienes deseen venir a vivir ya
estudiar aquí en el reino unido para los
ciudadanos europeos es un sistema de
puntos deben demostrar suficiencia en
inglés que tienen calificaciones para
aplicar en un trabajo aquí y en algunos
casos deben demostrar que tienen ya un
contrato laboral así que los cambios
serán significativos también ok por esta
pandemia no se puede viajar los
británicos y los europeos empezarán a
ver una transformación porque tendrán
que hacer fila como los otros ciudadanos
que ingresan a los aeropuertos del reino
unido y de la unión europea pues de la
información con luisa pulido
corresponsal de france 24 en londres
feliz año para usted luisa y entretanto
las principales naciones europeas
celebran el acuerdo que evitó un posible
caos comercial y el continente el
gobierno alemán calificó de histórico el
pacto
aprobado previamente hablamos también
con nuestro corresponsal en berlín y
tomás de sparrow
el gobierno alemán no dudó en calificar
de histórico el acuerdo del pro éxito
entre la unión europea y reino unido-
asegurando que se logró un objetivo
clave evitar un cambio de año caótico
según indicó el ministro de exteriores
alemán algo más para las autoridades en
este país
el acuerdo es particularmente importante
desde un punto de vista político pues se
negoció y se concretó durante la
presidencia alemana del consejo europeo
que acaba de terminar y también por
supuesto es muy importante desde una
perspectiva económica pues reino unidos
uno de los principales socios
comerciales de alemania y un destino
clave para las exportaciones de este
país
el gobierno alemán quizás habría querido
que el acuerdo tuviera un mayor
componente sobre las relaciones futuras
en temas de seguridad o de política
exterior pero igual se mostró confiado
en que servirá de base para las
relaciones futuras relaciones que por
cierto han estado marcadas en los
últimos días por las críticas hacia
merkel de sectores conservadores
británicos explican que no ha habido
confianza entre angela merkel y el
primer ministro británico
boris johnson y que fue el merkel la que
bloqueó intentos anteriores de lograr un
acuerdo en la prensa conservadora
británica incluso se refieren a merkel
como found line o la señora no cuando le
preguntaron a merkel por ello aquí en
berlín ella explicó de manera muy
concreta que no fue ella la que negoció
el acuerdo y que por el contrario estuvo
siempre en manos de la comisión europea
entre tanto el mundo celebra el fin de
año en medio de estrictas restricciones
en busca de frenar los contagios de ccoo
y 19 y américa latina no es la excepción
algunas naciones han optado por los
toques de queda mientras que otras han
implementado medidas restrictivas
respecto al consumo de alcohol o
reuniones familiares veamos el informe
de valentina torre sánchez
hay temor entre las autoridades y gran
parte de la población latinoamericana
por los aumentos en casos de kobe 19
registrados durante la época decembrina
por ello las restricciones son el común
denominador para este fin de año en
panamá fue decretada la cuarentena total
desde el primero hasta el 4 de enero y
en el país rige la ley seca desde el
pasado día 18 entre las 7 de la noche y
hasta las 5 de la mañana
en ciudad de mexico los comercios no
esenciales continuarán cerrados y habrá
ley seca entre el primero y el 3 de
enero en ocho de las 16 alcaldías de la
capital en bogotá la capital de colombia
las autoridades descartaron el 'toque de
queda' para el 31 de diciembre pero
prohibieron la venta y consumo de
alcohol en establecimientos y lugares
públicos asimismo desde hace una semana
se implementó el llamado pico y cédula
que solo permite el acceso a comercios y
otros sitios de acuerdo con el último
dígito del documento de identidad otras
ciudades se han implementado 'toque de
queda'
en ecuador el gobierno prohibió el
consumo de alcohol en lugares públicos
el 31 de diciembre y el primero de enero
y cerrará todas las playas en fin de año
en perú no circularán vehículos
particulares entre el 31 de diciembre y
el primero de enero y se decretó toque
de queda en lima entre las 11 de la
noche y las 4 de la mañana y en otras
provincias desde las 10 de la noche en
santiago la capital de chile se podrá
transitar libremente el 31 de diciembre
y realizar reuniones de máximo 15
personas pero habrá toques de queda
desde las 2 hasta las 7 de la mañana el
primero de enero en uruguay el gobierno
suspendió el ingreso al país entre el 21
de diciembre y el 10 de enero y se
redujo el aforo en centros comerciales y
otros establecimientos al tiempo que las
reuniones de fin de año no podrán
superar los 10 asistentes
en argentina y bolivia los gobiernos
recomendaron celebraciones de pocas
personas al aire libre y manteniendo el
distanciamiento social
el gobierno de china aprobó hoy su
primera vacuna de uso público contra el
coi 19 desarrollada por una filial de la
farmacéutica estatal scinopharm a la
aprobación que es condicional pues aún
faltan datos clínicos se produce un día
después de que si no farm anunciara que
la vacuna tiene una efectividad del 79,3
por ciento mira planearon ocular a 50
millones de personas con vacunas
nacionales antes de la celebración del
año nuevo lunar en febrero una de las
migraciones humanas más grandes del
planeta
y finalizamos con imágenes que nos
llegan desde nueva zelanda donde a esta
hora se viven los primeros minutos de
2021 a diferencia de otros lugares del
mundo con un espectáculo de fuegos
artificiales miles de neozelandeses
despidieron el 2020 dieron la bienvenida
al nuevo año después de que con un
combina miento estricto de siete semanas
logrará controlar el virus del coi 19 el
puente del puerto de oakland fue
inclinado por millones de luces para
celebrar la llegada del año nuevo
finalizamos construir en 324 punto com
[Música]
bien